what is it about Weston's it
particularly appeals to you well the the
period of time it's a romance you know
it's a marvelous romance I mean here you
have the knights of the round table and
here you have marvelous films you know
that all about King Arthur and about
everything dating is far back I mean
Game of Thrones is probably my favorite
well in fact some of the people are here
I must see them you know Game of Thrones
is my favorite television show now and
that whole period of the medieval time
is strictly licensed to you I mean
strictly license to the English and
maybe the Borgias you know being a
little bit later the French you know
medieval times and all but I enjoy so
much the period of the West the period
of the past you know the toughness of
the frontier the loneliness of the
gunfighter the loneliness of the farmer
the loneliness of the sheriff or the
marshal and how difficult was to
cultivate America in those days and
people forget about that we all get
caught up in what we need now you know
and it was tough within much tougher so
I'm and I'm also attracted to the legacy
that I'd like to leave to my children
who are small who don't know who Orton
raised on the 60s westerns the Mavericks
the Sugarfoot the Hebgen would travel
the gunsmoke's you know I was raised on
all those movies in the 60s and
television shows and you know
Magnificent Seven the good the bad the
ugly all those things I'd like to sort
of introduce a little bit of that to
them it's a different time in space in
the genre itself as a slow-moving genre
which is why it's so tough to produce
these days you know but I'd like to you
know make them more aware of what the
American heritage of cinema was all
about your own particular one you
mentioned obviously wise her which you
were in but of your own the West is that
you were watching when you were growing
up which are the ones particularly have
a warm place in your heart stone well
Red River you know
which was just marvelous Howard Hawks
directed that John Wayne and The
Searchers I really enjoyed my Bible is
really the Wild Bunch directed by Sam
Peckinpah I love that film but I've met
Serge Leone you know and had a marvelous
time with Sergio and and the good the
bad and the ugly and once by the time in
the West you know two of my favorites I
just love the Italian Western and and
it's a ballet unto itself you know and I
think that like Clint said once it's
time to retrieve the Western from
historical cinema that someone's going
to come up with a new twist you know and
certainly true True Grit was great but
still not green lighting a lot of
westerns and it cost 38 million and made
250 million if you know contemporary
movie did that they would release that
horror genre the police genre well the
special effects on write ten of them
would go on in a minute as greenlit
productions but with a Western sent over
exposed genre it's a tough sell you see
yourself on the screen or behind the
camera or a bit of bows for that well
I've directed a lot it you know a lot of
little westerns and plays and we just
were in Phoenix directed my son in a
Western in an after theater and it was a
guess and I would like to direct I have
one with vampires in it and but it's an
historical drama and it's a Western to
get young kids into the theater through
the back door to see the Western because
there's vampires in it you know it so
unlike Abraham Lincoln Vampire Slayer in
the sense that has women mostly but yeah
I've directed you know several things
and I really enjoy it it's just it's a
lot of work good luck with it it's been
let me just meet you Martin and I hope
to see you
here in the future thank you so much
you